Il quantum computing è entrato nell'era dell'utilità
il che significa che possiamo iniziare a usare i computer quantistici per risolvere
problemi del mondo reale, inclusi alcuni molto difficili
per i computer classici
un tema comune nell'era attuale
è che un problema viene risolto
per la prima volta su un computer quantistico
e poi le persone trovano un modo per farlo su un computer classico
questo ciclo di computing classico
e quantum computing che si spingono a vicenda ai loro
limiti probabilmente continuerà
per qualche anno ci sono classi di problemi in cui il quantum
computing può avere un vantaggio dimostrabile
rispetto al computing classico
dati i progressi in aree come
la riduzione degli errori e il numero di qubit disponibili
ci sono anche interi settori applicativi
in cui il quantum computing
potrebbe essere utile nel breve-medio termine
una di queste aree è il quantum machine learning o QML
il quantum machine learning si riferisce a
l'applicazione del quantum computing a qualsiasi tipo di processo
di machine learning esistono ovviamente
molti tipi di machine learning
due tipi di particolare interesse sono
l'apprendimento supervisionato in cui
si addestra un algoritmo usando un dataset etichettato
e l'apprendimento non supervisionato in cui
l'algoritmo lavora su campioni non etichettati
e cerca di imparare la distribuzione
o la funzione che la genera
un algoritmo non supervisionato potrebbe
ad esempio imparare come generare nuovi campioni
dalla stessa distribuzione oppure come
raggruppare i campioni in gruppi con caratteristiche simili
sia l'apprendimento supervisionato che quello non supervisionato spesso comportano
l'embedding dei dati in spazi di dimensione superiore
e la manipolazione dei dati in spazi di dimensione superiore
dovrebbe farci pensare al quantum computing
lasciami spiegare immagina di dover risolvere il problema di
classificare un punto dati sul piano
come cerchio o croce, dati i dati di training etichettati qui
a volte i dati possono essere chiaramente separati da una linea
o da un piano in basse dimensioni
come mostrato qui e classificare questi punti dati in base
a quelli sopra la linea
e quelli sotto la linea dovrebbe essere
semplice ma guarda questa distribuzione
chiaramente non c'è una linea visibile che separi i punti dati
tuttavia per questi dati potremmo immaginare una certa
mappatura da due dimensioni a tre dimensioni
tale che dopo aver applicato la mappatura i nostri dati appaiono
così e c'è chiaramente un piano che separa le due
classi che possiamo usare
per la classificazione se questo approccio sembra un po' semplicistico
hai ragione non possiamo semplicemente spostare i punti dati
più in alto senza giustificazione
deve esserci una mappatura
dalla distribuzione 2D che separi efficacemente
i nostri punti dati così possiamo
usare la mappatura per classificare nuovi punti dati
questo verrà discusso più approfonditamente nella lezione sul
riepilogo del machine learning ma basti dire
che il problema può essere visto
come il tentativo di molte mappature diverse in questo spazio di
dimensione superiore per vedere quali mappature producono la migliore
separazione dei punti dati di classi diverse
questa manipolazione dei dati in dimensioni superiori
è un'area in cui il quantum computing
potrebbe avere un grande impatto per capire perché
torniamo alle differenze tra computing classico
e quantum computing proprio
come i computer classici usano bit di informazione
i computer quantistici usano qubit
ma per un dato numero di bit, diciamo quattro
un computer classico può assumere uno qualsiasi dei
due alla quattro, ovvero sedici possibili stati
un computer quantistico può accedere anch'esso a sedici possibili stati
ma può esistere in una sovrapposizione di tutti
e sedici stati simultaneamente
e le operazioni possono essere eseguite sull'intera sovrapposizione
per quattro qubit questo potrebbe non sembrare
un gran che ma immagina cosa si potrebbe fare con
un computer quantistico in due alla venti o
due alla centoventisei
stati simultaneamente ci sono molte altre differenze
tra il computing classico e quello quantistico che
giocheranno tutte un ruolo in questo argomento
gli stati quantistici hanno ampiezze di probabilità complesse
le manipolazioni dei sistemi quantistici vengono eseguite con
operatori unitari e i computer quantistici sono soggetti a diversi
tipi di rumore rispetto ai computer classici
queste differenze emergeranno
in tutto il tuo lavoro di quantum machine learning in aree
come la codifica dei dati, il feature mapping e la mitigazione degli errori
in alcuni casi queste differenze tra computer classici
e computer quantistici ci permettono di progettare
nuovi algoritmi del tutto nuovi bene quella era una panoramica molto breve
sull'unione di due campi immensamente complessi
ma si spera che due cose siano chiare
il machine learning spesso risolve problemi
manipolando i dati in dimensioni molto elevate
e in secondo luogo i computer quantistici sono adatti
a manipolare i dati in dimensioni elevate
e lo fanno in modo diverso rispetto ai sistemi classici
questo dovrebbe darti un'idea
del perché il machine learning è un campo promettente
per l'applicazione del quantum computing utile